[Music]
what makes world-building so important
in anime and manga what sets these two
apart as genres from other forms of
storytelling is their unique use of
visual elements compared to a novel that
is purely text-based and relies
completely on describing every bit of
context that the author wants to convey
using words a manga embeds its dialogue
and plot into a visual framework for the
reader to see and feel rather than leech
and interprets in essence it allows
capturing the most significant moments
of a story by combining two mediums at
the same time film and text every panel
in the story is like a frozen frame
carefully chosen to catch the instant
carrying the best meaning and emotion
for the reader and in the hands of the
right person this hybrid forum can allow
for a unique way of storytelling
combining the advantages of visual and
textual elements alike so while it gives
us the effortless feeling of watching a
scene unfold on screen it still manages
to retain the readers need for
interpretation and an extension also
participation in the story by only
showing us a fraction of what is
happening a moment captured in time and
nothing but plain text for dialogues and
description manga leaves a lot more to
the reader than a movie would while
still showing a much clearer picture of
the world than any book could do anime
then of course takes this a step further
and brings that story into the medium of
film completely being able to witness a
story unfold by seeing the characters
actions and emotions with your own eyes
can without any doubt be a great
experience however as you probably are
aware emotions and thoughts can be
depicted in a non visual way just as
well and in some cases may be in even
more detail the true power then of the
visual nature of anime and manga lies
somewhere else what really affects its
audience the most and what makes the
genre so intriguing for people to follow
is the vast and rich story world it
creates in other words world building
I think everyone has made the experience
of becoming obsessed with the world of a
story they love this obsession becomes
strikingly clear when looking at
franchises like Game of Thrones Harry
Potter or Lord of the Rings where well
building has been taken to an entirely
new level what makes these vast worlds
with deep reaching lore countless
regions and even unique language is so
fascinating to us is our deep desire to
lose ourselves in the stories we love we
are looking for a way to keep the story
going and explore even more of its
facets and adventures however simply
cramming as much detail and additional
information into your storytelling won't
make people fall in love with it a
lesson that many authors and writers
have had to learn before great world
building them is a lot more than simply
overloading the audience with heaps of
information and impressive visuals in
fact introducing more and more elements
of a world that don't directly influence
the story at hand can lead to a rapid
drop in tension in your storyline and
ultimately result in the audience losing
interest so what makes a good story
world's and what sets this world that
you enjoy so much losing yourself in
apart from others in a good story the
world is a representation of the inner
and more personal struggles of the
protagonist it is a physical
representation of the most essential
elements of storytelling conflict
emotion symbolism and development all
these things that drive the plots and
get you involved into the characters and
their actions have to be connected to
the world this story takes place in in
some way of form so it's important that
each new element of the physical story
world has a connection to the events at
hands and enriches the context under
which they take place once this arena
resonates with the plot the audience now
can start to enrich and expand this
world in their own minds without needing
any specific instructions now we
actually want to know more about this
universe that has brought forth and
shape our heroes this way we assured
that the plot and the characters
involved feel like an organic
part of the world they are in their
struggles and the world struggles now go
hand in hand so how is such a story
world created how does it influence your
perception of the story and even more
specifically why does it make manga and
anime so enjoyable to watch we will now
explore these questions using the
example of one piece but once you finish
this video you will be able to apply
these principles to any other great
story you encounter and no worries blood
wise this case study will be 100%
spoiler free if you are unfamiliar with
the story of woman's it follows The
Adventures of a young pirate monkey Dee
Luffy and his crew to explore the world
and become the king of the Pirates this
may sound a little bit weird at first
but the overarching premise of the story
is already deeply connected to the story
world it occurs in because the world of
one piece is actually a world of pirates
the arena flower story is an entire
planet that is mostly covered by ocean
with the exception of a single slim
continent that spans around the globe
like a wall and is inaccessible to all
but a small ruling class all inhabitable
and exists in the form of islands spread
across the world this ruling class
dominates the entire population of the
world the only exception to this are
pirates who roam the oceans freely and
openly oppose the control and rules set
by this world government the evil rulers
live on top of this single continuous
landmass that separates the world
looking down on the rest of the people a
dangerous and wild ocean called the
grand line splits the world in the other
direction forming for isolated regions
this world is constructed in a way that
keeps people from moving around and
interacting with others as you can see
the story world already is a physical
representation of the political
structures as well as of the resulting
injustice and suppression happening in
this world the only ones that do move
around freely are those that oppose the
regime and since the world is completely
made up of water and Islands these
people are pirates
thus the premise of the plot being a
pirate story
this is the system and environment that
our hero lives in now take a moment and
think about this world just by looking
at its physical structure and geography
can you tell what the overarching
struggle of the story will be it's
actually pretty clear right even if you
know nothing about the story of one
piece you guess that this will be a
story about gaining freedom and changing
the world to fulfill this goal our
protagonist is sent on a journey through
this arena and while this world has many
different assets regions and cultures
the overarching threat posed by this
world government does not change no
matter where you go so while it feels
like we're changing places a lot that
overarching arena stays the same
however this arena will have to change
over time as well as the hero changes in
it so while Luffy is on a journey to
become the Pirate King the freest person
in the world this goal actually also
implies destroying the current system of
oppression and changing the world itself
the hero struggle is the world struggle
by becoming free himself he frees the
world this is what makes the story feel
so organic the characters we meet are a
real part of this universe and not just
a group of people dropped onto a
nice-lookin stage so now that we looked
at the overall structure of a story
world let's get a little bit more into
the specific details of world-building
[Music]
one of the most prominent elements of
any story world is the natural setting
that serves as the framework for the
plot to take place typical examples from
nature are the mountains the forests or
the deserts
while there are also man-made spaces
like cities or villages each of these
settings has a unique set of
characteristics and implications for the
story that go far beyond simple
geography to explain this a little bit
more in depth let's look at the two most
prominent natural settings in the story
of one piece the ocean and the islands
the ocean makes up large parts of the
planet one piece takes place on as a
stage for our plots it once again can be
divided into two distinct zones the
surface and the depths the surface is
the ultimate two-dimensional landscape
like a huge chessboard it is the playing
field for the characters with islands
sprinkled across the map it is here that
the journey between the different
destinations takes place and where
weather phenomena and other ships are
pretty much the only other encounters
for the crew the ocean surface is the
representation of the freedom that the
hero's yearning for and it's infinite
horizon opens up to an infinite number
of possible destinations on the other
hand the depth of the ocean are the
ultimate three-dimensional space
compared to the freedom of the surface
that dark and endless waters beneath it
are associated with danger and the
unknown it is in this weightless realm
where ancient worlds lie hidden terrible
monsters lurk and old secrets and
treasures way to be discovered while the
ocean may be by far the biggest setting
in the story of one piece apart from a
few exceptions it is mostly the medium
to travel from one adventure to the next
the real setting where most of the plot
and scream time takes place however are
the islands that lie on its surface not
only do these islands serve as a
representation of the suppression by the
world governments they are also
perfectly suited for an episodic story
like one piece being completely isolated
by the rest of the world an island is
the perfect premise to explore a
distinct social context having a small
and easily
prehensile culture and philosophy on
every new island is the perfect chance
to create individual story arcs with
their own subplots this makes every
island into a unique setting where you
things can be tested and individual
development becomes very pronounced one
way this is often utilized in the
context of anime and manga is in the
context of training where one's ability
can grow and develop in an isolated
place and where development can easily
be compared in the context of one piece
this often takes place in the form of
battle against a villain that dominates
set islands and in that sense every
island is also a miniature of the world
at large all of this allows for a very
complex and detail rich experience which
in turn works perfectly with the visual
capabilities of anime and manga
typically an island is integrated into
the plot as follows first the characters
from the world we're familiar with
arrive in a new place with distinct
rules and values then there is some sort
of struggle or challenge that has to be
overcome
usually a villain and finally this
conflict then has to be solved which
involves personal growth by the
protagonists this premise allows the
author to experiment with new concepts
and ideas in one piece in particular but
also in other stories these islands
often also have different natural
settings themselves some resemble
deserts others mountains and again
others jungles thus a broad variety of
settings can be utilized and explored
while at the same time still following
the overall theme of the island another
very important part of physical world
building is the weather while at first
glance this might sound not very
exciting weather has a profound and
striking influence on the mood and
emotion of a scene any good writer knows
how to use the weather to make the inner
life of a character visible to the
audience depending on the context most
weather phenomena can have positive or
negative connotations alike let's look
at a few examples
lightning and thunder can represent
passion or terror rain can be a sign of
coziness
or sadness wind can be relief and
tension alike
the Sun can symbolize happiness but it
can also be a false exterior and snow
can make a scene feel very peaceful but
it can also signify death next time you
watch an intense scene make sure to pay
attention to the weather and see how
it's used to enhance and intensify the
characters emotions to round things off
let's now look at some other important
elements of the story world that create
a more fascinating and organic
experience for the reader these are
elements that aren't 100% necessary for
a story to be great but if used
correctly can make a huge difference one
of these elements that is being used in
one piece is the concept of the vehicle
Luffy and his crew travel on board of a
ship that brings them from A to B
however this ship also represents a sort
of home for the protagonists it is a
moving house that gives the audience a
sense of safety and comfort once the
house is left a new adventure begins in
the dangerous world outside this helps
us for in a sense of continually by
serving as an anchor point
despite the ever-changing landscape
another great element to shift the
perspective of the viewer is to play
around with size one piece is a story
that particularly likes to play with the
concept of size in terms of landscape
creatures or architecture enormous
constructions and beings have a profound
impact on the readers experience no
matter if it's the gigantic gates of
Justice enormous sea monsters or the
size of some of the characters involved
having them put in contrast with our
perception of normal lets us witness the
world we thought we knew from entirely
new perspective and allow for an
exciting shift in perception then of
course there is technology and culture
as a whole having a unique set of
machines and weapons as well as distinct
religious or cultural concepts
integrated into the world in a way that
feels natural broadens our
of this world immensely especially in
anime and manga but also in other
fantasy series this often includes
magical powers or other forms of power
systems that are woven into this world
in the context of one piece these are
the concepts of hockey or willpower and
the so called devil fruits that bestow
unique powers upon those that consume
them these systems have to follow
distinct rules that explain why the
world is the way it is and why the
characters ended up with the level of
knowledge power and technology that they
have last but not least I want to
mention the use of gateways to other
worlds that can be used to create a
harsh cut in between scenes and
locations and throw the hero into
unknown territory in one piece this
concept is used quite often like
entering the dangerous Grand Line
through reverse Mountain visiting the
Fishman Island located at the bottom of
the ocean by diving into the depth of
the sea or entering the underwater
prison impel down that resembles Dante's
Inferno all of these elements are
important pieces that help establish a
story world that feels organic and
structurally consistent when you look at
other stories that you enjoy you will
see these principles reoccurring as long
as the author knows what he's doing and
of course there are many more elements
and settings to be explored that have
different rules and implications and yes
rules are also meant to be broken
however whatever variation is put on a
concept it must still make sense in the
context of the story that's being told
specifically in anime and manga world
building is one of the most important
pieces with it's often romantic and
solemn vibe bringing a unique story
world to life is in a way the secret
ingredient to this genre this is what
makes world building so important
if you enjoy this kind of video and want
to become part of the channel consider
hitting the subscribe button and leaving
a thumbs up on this video also I want to
say thank you to all of you who have
followed and supported my work this past
year you have made my first year on
YouTube extremely special I wish you all
happy holidays and a great start into
the year 2020 let's make it a good one
[Music]